any point during Blake keV live from
South by Southwest 2013 Austin Texas yo
its power 98.3 man bootleg Capcom we are
hanging out with chanel west coast
yo what up what's up girl you doing [ __ ]
I'm good you got your little American
bra popping off over here yeah you know
repping for America today and all that
[ __ ] why would you reprimand you know
chanel west coast
Chanel hey um is this your first time
out here second time I hear what's up
wow this is my first time at South by
are you liking it so far it's pretty
hectic
um I'm loving it I don't have you told
my voice but it is a little hoarse yeah
I've been going ham let's put it that
way we going ham sandwich yeah ham
sandwich I like it so everyone knows you
from the fantasy factory show that's
where you kind of like got some you know
I don't know publicity a same your fame
came from that and then your on your on
his show right now - ridiculous
ridiculousness or is it yeah yeah so um
you're a rapper and a lot of people
might not have tooken you seriously
because of the show they might think oh
this is just some girl from MTV yeah
it's a gimmick but you actually do rap
yes I actually do rap and I sing and I
dance um I've been doing music like my
whole life so that's what the [ __ ] she
does yeah I was doing music you know way
before I was on the show actually doing
music is kind of one of the things that
got Rob interested in me a word so
that's actually how I got on Fantasy
Factory like I rapped for one episode
and then he wanted me to be on it
permanently so that's dope yeah okay so
as far as making music um I always feel
like girls making hip-hop music can go
either really good or really bad because
a lot of girls like they decide to go
like super [ __ ] route or they talk
about like you know
hell no I am NOT on that ho [ __ ] that's
beautiful
and then there's not like that the only
other white girl rapping I think it
really is a Lea so um what's your lane
like what kind of what kind of hip-hop
are you make you make I party [ __ ] are
you trying to do um I mean really I like
make all different types of music um my
mixtapes about to dropped into this
month so when it does you guys will hear
it and um I think some of these I might
I might cause a problem for some of
these other micro rappers let's just put
it was a lot of people um yeah I think I
am I have I mean I got party songs I got
love songs um you know songs about my
life and coming up and just all
different types you know whatever I'm
feeling I make a song about it but when
I heard you talking about earlier you
have the little Wayne cosign uh yes I'm
Young Money now so um well your Young
Money
yeah I'm Young Money I know you Sonny um
I see people don't begin to tell you
this [ __ ] man not just cash money Young
Money Young Money
which is who you want to be down with
exactly ya know Wayne gave me the stamp
of approval and so you're signing to
Young Money yeah I have the same
management is Wayne Cortez Brian G Rover
Center my managers so so ya supposed to
be pretty poppin ASAP but you're gonna
blow the [ __ ] up yo I mean like already
more than you are
yeah I mean I like I don't know I'm not
really I don't know if I'm ready for it
but like I think I'll still always just
be this person that I am now so so what
have you um done any songs with Wayne
yet are you not yet no um I haven't I
actually he's been so busy like the past
few months like with his own album and
everything but that's gonna be happening
very soon you know if he's okay I heard
that yes he's okay um but obviously my
prayers still go out to him yeah shout
out TMZ
start a bunch of bulls yeah TMZ loves to
start [ __ ] not about me though thank
God they don't be talking [ __ ] about me
they will be soon I'm gonna wait thank
you because I'm a truck fit DJ and they
actually give me money so really okay
well thank you hey that guy's got
trusted over there right now
yeah I actually was just rocking a truck
bit hat uh yesterday so that's what's up
um okay so are you still doing you're
still doing ridiculousness with Rob yeah
um and the mixtape what is it called
what can we mean you got features on
there what's going on with the tape um
yeah there's a couple features really
it's more it's all really just like me
on it I kind of wanted to like come out
and not be one of the people like oh she
just poppin cuz she has to be bad people
just [ __ ] on your song exactly
so like I think the less features on my
first mixtape the better so that people
would look can people can really like if
you look at nas's album Illmatic he only
had one feature that's great he said by
love of all time yo exactly so that's
what's up
all right well I check out you know she
is doing her thing she's young money yep
young money in a building she runs
America buy her her lingerie and I rep
America presents house was Papa hey let
me ask you like as a chick I always
wonder do you get like dude groupies
because I was
like every guy out there like I got
groupies for Christ sakes I'm a [ __ ]
nobody yeah I get a lot of dude rupees I
actually get girl groupies to like I
don't know if it's because like I'm on a
show I'll participate in any of that
girl groupie action no comment
awesome yes no yeah I think that girls
like maybe think that like that I like
girls good like I'm never like would you
like girls like maybe sometimes um no
comment
well that just says it all though um but
yeah no I definitely got groupies that's
all how do you deal with like a male
group because I feel like it's like a
different dynamic like you guys have the
power anyway at all times and then you
real you got the power though [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] like george w bush
and like Raceland yeah no I mean they
get a little a little weird just because
like I feel like as a dude like you
should never put yourself in that
position where you're acting like kind
of thirsty sure so that's where it gets
a little weird like for girls I think
it's a little bit more normal for girls
like oh my god oh my god library you can
affect it almost so it's kind of a
turn-off you know like I don't think
guys realize like that is a turn-off to
like be like kind of groupies thirsty
ass fellas out there is yeah I just I
just post an Instagram the other day
always hungry never thirsty that's how
everybody should be Hey have you had an
interaction with Drake or Nikki at all
considering they actually haven't even
met Drake yet haven't met Nikki Wayne's
my boy though and Wayne's the one who
put me on so I'm about to meet everybody
soon you tell little Wayne to drop Bow
Wow um Ashley bowels not Young Money
bowels Cashman oh okay cool there's a
big difference people don't seem to
realize that actor there's a lot of cash
money here yeah there's cash money
artists and there's young money young
money is Wayne Drake Nicki Tyga and me
know got it got it too oh yeah I gotta
go to your drop gotta got it too I'm not
gonna make any call you know to saying I
got it I gotta have I gotta have the
team um you know got out there back lost
Sonya you little twist got some [ __ ]
though ours oh yeah the studio a little
twisted Vegas yes [ __ ]
I will twist is dope like 4n4 beam young
like six months ago I would have said
drop a little twist but I heard his [ __ ]
he's cool I'm not mad at to us but do
you know he's turning bieber out he was
turning into [ __ ] yeah beaver beavers a
young Juicy J Bieber's gonna end up in
jail get little to aspera
Bieber is Wilin out it's crazy too
because I met Bieber
when he was like 16 and iron
like I met him too when he was like 16 I
remember I had just went outside to
smoke and I felt like all guilty being
around him hi and now he's like smoking
all the time so I'm like okay cool he's
a little pothead lean sippin Molly
popping little guy man he's easy this
rap life is for Bieber I'm telling you
hey it was nice to meet you I'm looking
forward to checking out the mixtape oh
yes definitely it's gonna be out in two
this month so follow me on Twitter and
what's the name of the tape you know I
can't believe I don't have a name yet
but I want Nate I will have that
together in the next couple America
period be on the cover that [ __ ] in
that America brawl right oh my god
that's hilarious um no no what a lot of
people from the south will eat it up
because you're white and it's called
America no I don't think all you got to
do is have like a picture of Ronald
Reagan on there with it and no [ __ ] I
don't think they will but um yeah that's
what stuff check her out she know West
goes on Twitter right
yeah chanel west coast boom powered on
8.3 bootleg Capcom